اهلا بكم من جديد نتابع معكم تغطيتنا عبر
شاشه العربيه لتداعيات زلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب من تركيا وسوريا ونبدا هذه الساعه
بهذا الخبر حيث اعلن وزير النقل التركي
انقاذ طفله تبلغ من العمر اربعه اعوام بعد
نحو
180 ساعه في يمل
اذا ونحن ندخل اليوم الثامن تتغير البوصله
نحو احصاء الجثث بدل ناجين قد ارتفعت
حصيره القتلى الاجماليه الى نحو 37 الف
قتيل كان لتركيا نصيبه الاكبر منها باكثر
من
31,643 قتيلا
واضافت هيئه الكوارث التركيه ايضا الفي
حاله وفاء الى حصيله قتل الزلزال في اقل
من 24 ساعه في سوريا تم تسجيله خمسه الاف
و300
على الاقل من القتلى وذلك وفق ارقام
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان كذلك حدثت
اداره الكوارث التركيه ارقامها ايضا وقالت
ان
6444 مبنى دمرت بالكامل جراء زلزل
قدر اتحاد الشركات والاعمال في تركيا حجم
الاضرار الناجمه عن الزلزال بنحو عشره في
المئه من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للبلاد
فيما رجح الاتحاد ان مبان سكنيه تقدر
قيمتها بنحو السبعين مليار دولار دمرت الى
جانبي تعرض الدخل القومي لخسائر تقدر
بعشره مليارات دولار وتوقع الاتحاد ارتفاع
عزل الموازنه الى 5.4 من العشره في المئه
من المئه الناتج من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي في العام الحالي مقابل التقديرات
الرسميه البالغه ثلاثه ونصف قبل كارثه
الزلزال
وقد تحول ملعب هاتاي الجديد الى قريه خيام
لايواء السكان بعد الزلزال في حين تعمل في
انقاذ ليل نهار وسط انقاض الالاف من
المباني المنهاره
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى هاتاي الى جنوب تركيا ينضم الينا
من هناك منفذ العربيه اعمار الهندي اهلا
عمار ضعنا في اخر التطورة اهلا خالد
خالد العمليات طبعا في الاحياء المدمره
والبنيات المتبره لا تزال مستمره ولكن
الان كل التركيز على النزوح وعلى
عائلات التي فقدت يعني منازلها واين تذهب
ونحن هنا في مركز ايواء للسوريين تحديدا
الذين وقعت بناياتهم وانهدمت ومنهم من
تاذى واصيب ومنهم من لا يزال له اشخاص تحت
الانقاض ونستمع الى الحكايه لنعرف اكثر ما
الذي يحدث وكيف هي الحال طبعا
الاشخاص ياتون الى هنا العائلات تاتي الى
هنا الى هذا المركز خالد وبعد ذلك تنقل في
باصات الى مناطق ومدن ثانيه مثل بورصه
وهناك للاسف حسب ما علمت والان ستسمع من
اشخاص سنتحدث اليهم انه لا يوجد هنالك
ايضا توفير للمساعدات لهم ولا لايواءهم
ولكن هم كل ما يودون ان يحدثوا الخروج من
انطاكيا من هات لشده الدمار فيها ولشده
الخوف من الهزات الارتداديه التي ستحدث في
اي لحظه طبعا هنا شاب جاء من هاتاي من
انطاكيا كنت تحدثت اليك قبل المباشر
واخبرتني انه لا زال في اشخاص تحت الانقاد
لك وانت يعني فررت من هناك الى هذا المركز
وبدك تروح لمكان امن احكي لنا ايش اللي في
لحظات انت كنت فيه الزلزال طيب من الذي
يتواجد تحت الانقاذ حتى اللحظه موجود ابن
عمي
وابن صاحب المكتب كمان ورفيقهم موجودين
لحتى اللحظه يعني تحت المبنى امبارح اجتنا
اشاره انه احتمال في صوت فرحنا جبنا
اللجنه الروسيه الفريق الروسي الفريق
الروسي فحفروا يعني وحطوا جهاز النبض
وايام ما وصل شيء يعني اخر شيء حتى وصلنا
للمكان انه 90% يكونوا موجودين فيه فطلع
اللي ما موجودين يعني
بس جهاز كشف اصوات هلا في واحد قال سمعت
صوت قبل ما تيجي اللجنه الروسيه لهيك على
هالمبدا جبناهم يعني بس لحد هاللحظه هن
موجودين لانه الكشف الحراري انا انه في
ثلاث جثث جوه وانا ميتين يعني
انه ما خلينا طريقه انه خيو يعني بدنا
اياهم حتى ميتين يعني المهم نطمن يعني اخر
شيء يعني نعرف انه ندفنه لما كان وخلاص
نطلع من المنطقه مصيره اين ذهب وانت ايضا
متطوع بتنقل الناس من هدايا كثير عدد
العائلات والله كتير كتير يعني لحد اللحظه
حتى في ناس يعني بعرف انه رفيقي طالع
ومرته وابنه وبنته وهو مبين عليه هون يعني
فوق حديد تركوه
اللحظه يعني امنوا انه عرفوا مصيره بانه
توفى ولكن لم ينتشر ليش طيب ايش البنايه
صعب انتشاره يعني انه بدهم يامنوا على
الاحياء الاول يعني بدهم ينتقلوا لحدا
تاني انه يكون احياء الاولويه للاحياء
بس يعني انه شي صعب يعني حتى على العلاقه
وقت عم بشوف انه حدا يضل تحت الانقاذ حتى
لو ميت عم بنهر وبتركه لانه بده يروح
للاحياء او بده يهرب مثلا اخباريه بيروحوا
انه هون في احياء خلص بيبلشوا يعني
هذا وفي ناس ما بنعرف مصير عن رفقاتنا
وقرايبين قرايبين بشكل غير مباشر يعني
البناء كله فوقهن بدي اسالك سريعا عن
المساعدات الان هذا مركز ايواء يعني يعني
اقيم بالتعاون بشراكه مع مركز ملهم
ومتطوعين يعني ومطاعم جاءت من اسطنبول كيف
مستوى المساعدات فعليا احكيلنا عن مستوى
المساعده هلا هون مستوى المساعدات يعني
كتير كويس من السوريين السوريين طبعا بس
بقى اللي كتير يعني انه متضايقين يلي
طلعوا لبره سواء ولا باضنه يعني هون الاخ
بيعرف ساتحدث اليه عائلته موجوده يعني
حدثوها عن الوضع بيعرفوا يعني كتير عم
بيعانوا خصوصا بالمقوى عائلتك اشكرك
عائلتك نقلت من هون الى مكان اخر
على مرسين
في هلا نحن ثلاث عيال وعنا الوالده الحمد
لله علمت انا واولادي واخوي واولاده ومرته
ونسوان وكلياتهم نزلنا على مرسين بحيث
وحتى ماوى يعني حاولنا كتير يعني بالشارع
مثلا هلا في عنا اصدقائي عنا صديق فضه
بيته وقعدنا محله الزلمه قاعد عند بيت
اخته حتى كمان عنده عيال بتيجي كمان بده
يعني عائله قد ما فينا نضيع عليها زياده
كمان انا هو بدي اخذ راحته ببيتي بس مع
انه المشكله وضع هذا ماساوي على الكل مو
بس انا في كثير عيال سوريين نزلوا على
مرسين على اضنه على اسطنبول يعني وعلى
بورصه
لها يعني الله المستعان
تقدر توصف لنا ايش اللي صار والله اللي
صار هلا هو عباره عن رعب مثل ما يقولوا
ساعه الغفله يعني فجاه انت
تحتك مثل السداجه بتهز وانت نايم يعني بدك
تتحرك بدك تقوم تعبت ما بتعرف شو بدك
تساوي هون انا عندي قسم من البيت نزل
الحمد لله الدرج كان ساقين
جزء النهار وجزء شغال حتى نحن انا عائلتين
ساكنين ببيت واحد نزلناهم ونزلنا والدنيا
كانت يعني
اهم شيء انه ان شاء الله ما فقدت حدا
نجوتوا العائله نجت الحمد لله بس الابنيه
اللي حوالينا صدعت ونزلت كلياتها اغلبيتها
يعني وتسمع وانت
مسافه 20 متر تسمع اصوات
الاشخاص من تحت الابنيه بس ما تحسن تتحرك
لانه ما هديت هزات هزات يعني حتى استمعت
الى اصوات اشخاص ناجين تحت الانقاض استمعت
الانهار ونهارين بس ما في انك ترجع تحاول
انك تطا لانه اسه الهزات عم ترجع
ارتداديات وحتى اجوا فرق الانقاذ يعني حتى
فرق الانقاذ ما يساعدوا اول باول حتى يهدا
شوي الوضع ويعرفوا الاصوات منين عم تطلع
هلا كمان في كتير يعني كتير ناس ماتت من
خوفه وفزع على الدراج يعني في كثير عالم
كانت بغرفته على الهزات شالوا نزلوا على
الدرجة
اللي كانوا نايمين فيها مصر
شاهدنا كثير حالات هالامور والحمد لله رب
العالمين الحمد لله
خالد يعني
القصص والحكايه كثيره هنا ولكن هنالك على
ما يبدو ازمه في المساعدات بما يخص يعني
السوريين هم يعني طبعا اعدادهم كبيره جدا
في انطاكيا لانها تعتبر منطقه حدوديه مع
معبر باب الهوى قريبه جدا لا تبعد كثيرا
وبالتالي حينما يعني لجاوا لجاوا الى
تركيا على هذه المناطق استقروا فيها
وعملوا فيها وانجبوا وتكاثروا فيها وجاء
هذا الزلزال ليدمر ما بنوه في خلال
السنوات الماضيه ولكن الان حينما يفر من
البنايات المدمره والاحياء المدمره الى
مركز هذا يتم نقلهم الى مدن اخرى كما تحدث
الضيف وهناك لا توجد لا يوجد لهم ماوى لا
توجد لهم مساعدات وهذه ازمه جديده يعني
طبعا تخلق ازمه بعدها وازمه متتاليه ولا
اعرف حقيقه يعني كيف يمكن ان يكون هنالك
حل للازمه عامه عمار انها تختص بالسوريين
في هذه المنطقه هل لنا ان نفهم ماذا كنت
تقصد بان هذه الازمه يعني يعاني منها
السوريون
[موسيقى]
انا التقيت العدد عدد كبير جدا من
السوريين هنالك طبعا احاديث كثيره منهم
هنالك من يشعر باستياء بانه هنالك تقصير
مع السوريين هنالك من يطالب بمساعدات لانه
يعني وجد نفسه في لحظه من اللحظات مشرد في
الشارع هو اساسا فار من حرب الى بلد
اصابها زلزال تدمرت هذه المدن كلها
بالكامل وهنالك نوع من الاستياء نوع لديهم
باحساس بانه يعني لا يحظون بالدعم المناسب
والمساعده المناسبه هنا في انطاكيا وانا
اتحدث هنا عن عشرات الحالات التي سمعتها
خالد بهذا الصدد يعني هذه هذه الفكره
سمعتها من عشرات الاشخاص هنا في انطاكيا
ولديهم احتجاج ولذلك قام رجال اعمال او
تجار من هذه المدن ومن اسطنبول سوريين
بالاضافه بالتعاون مع فريق ملهم ومتطوعين
بانشاء هذا الماوى ليجلبوا هم طبعا لديهم
سيارات من متطوعين يذهبوا الى داخل
انطاكيا الى المدن والاحياء المدمره من
لديه من ليس لديه منزل ومشرد في و بقي في
الشارع يقوم بنقله على يعني على نفقتهم
الى هذا الماوى وبعد ذلك يخيرونهم عن لمدن
متعدده يختار الشخص المدين التي يرغب
بالذهاب اليها ربما يعرف احد هناك وحينما
يصل هناك يترك الامر للحظ حتى يتدبر نفسه
ولكن نعم هنالك نوع من الشكاوي الذي
السوريين بان هنالك تقصير سواء في عمليات
الاغاثه او المساعدات او الايواء
شكرا لك من هاتاي جنوب تركيا مفرد العربي
يعمر الهندي
نذهب الى منطقه مرداد في غازي عنتاب مع
زيدان ومراسل العربيه اهلا زيدان ايضا
ضعنا في اخر التطورات
نعم خالد اعمال لانقاذ في هذا الموقع هنا
في نورداغ مستمره كما تشاهدون عبر شاشه
العربيه فرق الانقاذ في هذا الموقع تحاول
منذ ساعات طويله الوصول الى اشخاص عالقين
تحت الانقاض وقبل قليل استطاعوا فتح فجوه
في تحت الركام ويبدو انهم احضن البطانيات
يبدو انهم
توصلوا او ربما هناك
جثث سيتم اخراجها بعد قليل من هذا المكان
كما نشاهد الان كان الحفر باليات بسيطه
لعدم
حدوث اي انهيارات قبل قليل كما ذكرت
احضروا البطانيات هناك بعض عمال الانقاذ
دخلوا او يحاولون اخراج الاشخاص العالقين
من تحت
الانقاض حتى الان لم يصرحوا هل هؤلاء
كانوا على قيد الحياه ام لا لكن يعني في
مثل هذه الحالات عندما يحضر البطانيات
ويضعونها حتى لا يستطيع احد من الموجودين
في هذا الموقع مشاهده ما يجري في مثل هذه
الحالات مع الاسف يكون هو اخراج جثث لكن
كان الحديث هنا او هم يحاولون الوصول الى
اشخاص عالقين لم يكن لديهم اي معلومات هل
هؤلاء هم على قيد الحياه ام لا لكن على ما
يبدو ان اليوم او في هذه اللحظات استطاعوا
فتح هذه الفجوه وكما نشاهد يعني تجمع
لعشرات من رجال لانقاذ ايضا بينهم فريق من
الهند يساعد ويشرف على عمليه البحث بينما
في المحيط جرافات كبيره تحاول جرف الانقاض
من الاماكن التي انتهى منها فريق البحث في
من عملهم وبالتالي فقط هذه النقطه التي
بقيت هي التي يحاولون الوصول اليها تقريبا
وصل الى الطوابق السفليه هذا المبنى
الذي نشاهده امامنا ونتابع معكم عبر شاشه
العربيه هذه اللحظات هناك طبعا قسم كبير
من اهالي نورداغ جاء الى هنا يحاول ان
يشاهد ما جرس او حاول يعني لحظات قليله ان
ارصد منظر الاهالي هنا على الجانب المجاور
في وهم يتابعون عمل رجال الانقاذ الكل
يريد ان يسمع خبر عن قريب او جار او صديق
تحت الانقاض كما تشاهدون الكل في حاله
ترقب
وطبعا هنا عناصر من الجيش التركي ايضا
تنتشر في هذا المكان كما تشاهدون دونهم
عند الجرافه يمنعون اي احد من الاقتراب
الى مكان عمل فريق الانقاذ
فريق الانقاذ هذا الذي نشاهده اليوم نحن
قدمنا الى النورداغ فجر هذا اليوم في
الساعه الرابعه صباحا وكانوا يعملون في
هذا الموقع وحد يعني غادرنا المكان في
تمام الساعه التاسعه صباحا وذهبنا الى
المخيمات القريبه وعدنا بعد ساعتين او
ثلاثه ساعات تقريبا وكان اعداد فرق
الانقاذ المتواجده المتواجده هنا قد
تضاعفت وجاء فريق كما ذكرت فريق من الهند
يشارك وايضا فريق اجنبي اخر لم اتاكد من
جنسيتهم احضروا ايضا فريق للكلاب المدربه
كان هنا في الجوار ايضا ساعدهم في الوصول
الى هذه النقطه التي نشاهدها الان
واستطاعوا فتح ثغره في الجدار ومن ثم قبل
قليل احضر البطانيات والان يتم انتشال
العالقين ننتظر حتى نعلم الان
طيب
كما نحاول ان اتابع هناك ازدحام بين رجال
الانقاذ
نعمل ان تكون ان يكون احد من اشخاص خالد
الذين كانوا عالقين ما زال على قيد الحياه
الاسيه مع ان رغم اننا في اليوم الثامن
لكن هذا اليوم شهد خروج العديد من الاشخاص
على قيد الحياه احدهم بعمر 26 عاما
على ما اعتقد كان في ولايه هاتاي تم
اخراجه معافى او ما زال على قيد الحياه
بعد 178 ساعه قضاها تحت الانقاض لذلك يعني
هذه الاخبار الايجابيه في الولايات الاخرى
كانت تعطي دفعا لرجال الانقاذ بواصلوا
العمل عسى ان يصلوا الى ناج اخر يضاف الى
قائمه الاشخاص الذين كتبت لهم الحياه بعد
هذا الزلزال المدمر والمروع حقيقه الذي
ضرب عاشر ولايات في جنوب تركيا طبعا هناك
الرجال الانقاذ ايضا تعمل في مواقع اخرى
في نوردا وولايه غازي عنتاب لكن في مواقع
ايضا تمكنوا من الانتهاء من الاعمال في
بعض المواقع
كثيره طبعا هنا نتحدث عن مدينه منكوبه
خالد
عفوا مدينه منكوبه شهدت دمارا كبيرا في
معظم المباني هنا سواء انهيار بالكامل او
دمار بشكل جزئي
ومباني كثيره لم تعد صالحه للسكن لذلك حجم
الدمار كبير وفرق الانقاذ تنتشر في اكثر
من موقع نعم اخرج جثه قبل قليل
نعم جثه اخرج جثه من تحت الانقاض
حتى الان الان جثه يضعونها او يتجهزون
لنقلها الى سياره الاسعاف القريبه
طيب ونحن نتابع معك هذه الصوره الان
لعمليات فرق الانقاذ من غازيه عن التاب
التي يعني تواصل عملها كذلك حسب ما ذكره
مراسم المتواجد الان على الارض زميلنا
زيدان زنكلو يتم الان ربما اخراج بعض
الجثث او الجثث من تحت انقاذ هذا المبنى
اريد فقط ان اذكر بالخبر العاجل الذي
اوردناه قبل قليل بابحار اول ناقله نفط من
ميناء جيهان التركي هذا الميناء الذي تسبب
الزلزال في التوقيف عملياته وعمليات ايضا
التدفق كذلك عبر خطوط الانابيب من لتصدير
النفط من
المناطق ايضا خاصه من كركوك شمال
العراق نتابع اذا هذه الصور لفرق الانقاذ
المتواجده الان في غازي عين تحديدا في
مدينه
المناطق التي طالها يعني تدمير كبير
للكثير من المباني فيها
بشكل يجعل الدمار ربما شبه كامل لهذه
المنطقه في مبانيه
تابع معك زيدان وانت تشاهد الان هذه
تحركاتها قبل الفرق الانقاد نعم نعم
كما ذكرنا قبل قليل اخرجوا وجوه من هذا
الموقع والعمل جاري للوصول الى بقيه
العالقين تحت الانقاض
سنتابع معكم طبعا هذه المدينه
هذه المدينه التي تشاهد او هذه المدينه
التي نتواجد فيها اتى الدمار على قسم كبير
من المباني والتصدع عشرات المباني الاخرى
وباتت غير صالحه للسكن دمار في معظم البنى
التحتيه في هذه المدينه وانقطاع لخدمات
الكهرباء
والماء وايضا للغاز الطبيعي المعد
الغاز الطبيعي الذي يستخدم في التدفئه
طبعا هناك عشرات او عده عده مخيمات اقيمت
على عجل لاستيعاب
الاشخاص الذين اصبحوا بلا ماوى وايضا
بلديه غازي عنتاب تقوم بتجهيز مخيم مكون
من كرفانات كما تسمى هنا
كحل افضل من
الحل الحالي وهو الخيام ايضا هو حل مؤقت
لحين نقل قسم من الاهالي الى ولايات اخرى
ومن ثم
ذهابهم الى سكن مؤقت ربما هو السكن
الجامعي في ولايات متفرقه بعيده عن
المناطق المتضرره ريثما تبدا عمليه اعاده
الاعمار وتعود الحياه الى طبيعتها يعني
نحن هنا نحتاج يعني في هذه المدينه ربما
احياء جديده
واحياء جديده بالكامل وخدمات يجب ان تؤسس
مراكز خدمات بالكامل حتى محطات الوقود
تقريبا جميعها معطله ولا يوجد فيها اي الا
ما ندر محطات وقود ما زالت تعمل وبالتالي
هناك حاجه للخدمات في كل المجالات حتى
المساجد دمرت هنا قسم كبير من المساجد
دمره في هذه المدينه لذلك الوضع هنا سيء
وسيء جدا هذه مدينه يمكن وصفها بالمدينه
المنكوبه طبعا اضافه الى مدينه اصلاحيه
القريبه من هذه المدينه ايضا تتبع الولايه
غازي عنتاب
هاتين المدينتين هما من اكثر المناطق
تضررا في ولايه غازي عنتاب نعم هناك اضرار
في مركز مدينه غازي عنتاب التي تبعد عن
هنا حوالي 60 كيلومتر لكن في نوردا وفي
اصلاحيه حجم الدمار اكبر بكثير مع الاسف
احياء ردمت بالكامل هذا المبنى الذي
نتواجد فيه الان هو يعني ايضا من ضمن الحي
كامل انهار على
سكانه مع الاسف
ودمر بالكامل وهذا الحي مشابه لاحياء
زرناها هنا في نوردا ايضا تدمرت وانهارت
بفعل الزلزال
نحاول معكم الان رصد المشهد هنا ايضا
تستمر الجهود يعني هذه المدينه مع الاسف
يعني كانت مركز لاقوى هزه ارتداديه شهدتها
البلاد بعد الزلزال وكانت بقوه 6.6 يوم
الاثنين الماضي بعد حدوث الزلزال الاول
الذي كان مركزه كهرمان مرعش وكان بقوه 7.8
بعد ربع ساعه فقط
حدثت هزه ارتداديه هنا بقوه 6.6 ادت الى
دمار كبير في الابنيه التي تصدعت من
الزلزال الاول ولم تنهار ومن ثم جاء
الزلزال الثاني بعد عده ساعات في الساعه
الواحده وربع بعد الظهر يوم الاثنين
الماضي اي قبل اسبوع وكانت بقوه 7.6 زيدان
شكرا جزيلا لك ربما نعود اليك في حلقه
جديده اي معلومات وتطورات
حول ما يحدث الان من قبل فرق الانقاذ
المتواجده حيث شكرا جزيلا لك زيدان زنكلو
مراسل العربيه في غازي عنتاب
الله
وبعد اسبوع من الزلزال المدمر بدا
المنكوبون يستيقظون على حقيقه انهم فقدوا
اهاليهم وفقدوا ايضا ممتلكاتهم وسط غموض
بشان خطط الحكومه التركيه لاعاده الامور
الى نصابها
جيد او سيء كل ما نملكه كان هنا حتى
اطفالي يبكون ويقولون امي لقد ذهب كل شيء
وذهب الطفولتنا وذكرياتنا معظم مجري ما
كانوا عملي كل شيء دمر بيتي دمر كان لدي
مستودع واحد قد اختفى الان ليس لدي اي شيء
ذهب كل شيء واصبحنا في الشارع
لم يكن مثل اي زلزال اخر دمرت الطرق ودمرت
منازلنا ولم يتبقى اي مبنى اختفى كل شيء
لا احد يعرف كيف سنعيش
الجو بارد وسنتجمد هنا حتى الموت اذا
جلسنا داخل الخيمه فسوف نتجمد
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي طه عوده سيد طه مرحبا بك معي في
هذه المتابعه والتغطيه عبر شاشه العربيه
يبدو انما شاهدناه وما نشاهده ايضا
باستمرار من حجم الدمار الذي خلفه على كل
المستويات يعني في المدن والولايات
والمناطق والقرى التركيه لن يقف عند هذا
الحد وان ذلك سيكون سببا ربما في زلزال
سياسي اقوى ينتظر الان تركيا والعليه يبدا
معك من اكثر الاسئله التي بدات يعني
تلحن الان وهو التركيز على يعني طريقه
تفاعل الحكومه ومدى استجابتها لهذه الحاله
الطارئه يعني صحيح ان حجم الزلزال كان
كبيرا
والى درجه انه اي حكومه لن تكون جاهزه
بهذا بشكل مطلوب للاستجابه لكن اليوم
يتحدث
الاتراك الكثير الاهالي والسكان لهذه
المناطق بان
عن النقص التام في في في من ناحيه جهود
الاغاثه الخدمات الطوارئ
الاسعاف الانقاذ الخيام المساعدات الغذاء
لا شيء منها كما يقولون يصلهم بشكل
المطلوب حتى الان ما رايك في هذا الكلام
تحياتي لك في البدايه استاذ خالد
المشاهدين نحن نعيش الان ماستان الاولى هي
الى حتى هذه اللحظه تحت الانقاد واقصد هنا
البحث عن ناجين لم تتوقف عملياتها الانقاذ
وماساه اخرى هي فوق الانقاض وهي متعلقه
بتشريد عدد كبير او الاف مئات الالاف من
المواطنين هناك نعم كما تفضلت هناك من مات
تحت الانقاذ ولكن حاليا ما فوق الانقاذ هو
السؤال المطروح لسوف يطرح خلال الايام
المقبله فيما يتعلق بعمليه الايواء فيما
يتعلق بعمليه
سكانيهم ويعني عمليه اجلاء حصلت عدد كبير
من المدن هناك تصور اعتقد تحديات صعبه
تواجه الحكومه التركيه خلال المرحله
المقبل هذه التحديات تتمثل بالدرجه الاولى
موجه نظري بسؤال سوف يطرح بالدرجه الاولى
من قبل الشارع التركي والمواطن التركي
وبين قوسين هو يوم الحساب انا اتصور اعتقد
معاون تركيا سوف تناقش وسوف وتترقف هذه
المساله خلال ايام المقبله ويطرح هذا في
البرلمان موضوع يعني هناك بعض المعارضين
واقصد هنا رئيس باريس اسطنبول تحدثت قبل
بالامس في احدى التغريدات هل هي كارثه
العصر ام اهمال العصر هذا هو ممكن ان يطرح
خلال الايام المقبله الحكومه التركيه قامت
بخطوات جباره استنفار على كافه
المستويات وزراء ولكن هي لم تقنع وجهه
نظري حتى هذه اللحظه الشارع التركي خاصه
اذا تحدثنا عن ان هناك بنايات ومباني
جديده وحديثه تهدمت كالورق
عمليات اعتقالات تحصل من الحين الاخر هناك
مذكره لمئه وثلاثه عشر شخصا ولكن كلها
ممكن نصفها بين قوسين هي امتصاص الغضب
الشارع التركي اعتقد اذا حتى اللحظه لم
تنقشع غبار هذه الكارثه ولكن في الايام
المقبله سوف نرى هناك يعني ازمه كبيره وان
صح التعبير زلزال سياسي اخر سوف يكون بين
الاروع السياسيه في انقره يسالون كذلك عن
الاموال يعني اموال الطوارئ المخصصه على
وجه التحديد للاغاثه انت تعلم سيد طه بانه
في عقاب الزلزال المميت عام 99
كان هناك او اقرت الدوله صندوقا لمواجهه
يعني التحديات والكوارث الطبيعيه ومنها
الزلازل يعني بالتاكيد وفرضت الدوله
الضريبه دائمه على جميع ملكي المنازل
الاتراك للمساهمه في هذا الصندوق
التقديرات تتحدث على ان الدوله جمعت ما
يقرب من اربعين مليون او مليار عفوا 40
مليار دولار في هذا الصندوق يعني اين
ذهبت هذه الاموال اذا بالفعل يعني لم نجد
فرق انقاذ كافيه ليس هناك اي معدات كافيه
بعض المعدات اللازمه المطلوبه غير موجوده
في الاساس بعض المساعدات ليست موجوده في
الاساس لا توجد اي مناطق كافيه لاستيعاب
هؤلاء المهجرين والمشردين ولا
وليس هناك اي خطه ايضا معلومه او واضحه عن
كيفيه التعامل مع كل هذه الاعداد يعني
لا تصور اعتقد هناك الحكومه التركيه بعد
كارثه 99 وضعت استراتيجيه وكما تفضلت هناك
ضريبه يعني تدفع من كل مواطن نحن كل سنه
ندفع كل ملك بيت يدفع هذه الضريبيه ضريبه
الزلزال تسمى هنا وهناك اموال نعم اغدقات
ولكن كان التركيز بشكل كبير على تغيير
البنيه التحتيه في عدد كبير من المناطق
وحتى المناطق هنا في اسطنبول يقومون
بعمليات رصد وعمليات دائما تجهيز ولكن
كانت الصدمه وانفجعه الكبرى هي لم يتم
الاهتمام في المناطق الاخرى التي شهدت
فيها
ضرر واقصد مقاطعات العشره يعني حتى هناك
اسئله سوف تطرح خلال الايام المقبله بان
هناك ما يقارب 128 الف منزل هنا في
اسطنبول هو معرض للزلزال اذا لا سمح الله
وقعت هزه كبيره كما شاهدناها لذا اعتقد
هناك اسئله كبيره سوف تطرح
الاكبر والاصعب من وجهه نظري هو من الشارع
التركي خاصه ان الحكومه التركيه والمعارضه
جميعهم توجهون بعد اشهر قليله الى
انتخابات برلمانيه رئاسيه حاسمه وعلى
الضوء هناك يعني التصريحات وعلى الخطوات
التي سوف تقدمها او تطمينات تقدمها
الحكومه سوف تكون هناك النتيجه في صناديق
الاقتراع وخاصه في هذه الانتخابات هناك
حقيقه بعض الاخطاء ارتكبت حتى ان الرئيس
اردوغان تحدث عن تقصير حتى نائب الرئيس
الرئيس تحدث عن هناك عدم التنظيم ويحصل
عدم التنظيم
على هذا الدمار الان هل سيتم محاسبه
المقاولين لانه هناك تحركات للقبض لاعتقال
بعض المقاولين هل سيتم التركيز عليهم
تحميلهم هذه المسؤوليه ام سيتم بحث الامر
والمحاسبه لقطاع اكبر نتحدث عن مسؤولين
الذين كان بيدهم ايضا اعطاء هذه التصاريح
لبناء هذه لهذه البنايات رغم عدم
استيفائها لاي شروط او مواصفات
يعني انا اتصور اعتقد المقاولين هي فقط هي
ورقه انا متصور اعتقد يعني هناك البحث سوف
يكون اعمق بكثير واقصد هناك من غض الطرف
وخاصه الحكومه التركيه خلال سنوات الماضيه
انفردت هناك قوانين وهذه القوانين لم يتم
تنفيذها او يتم تنفيذها من قبل هؤلاء
المقاولين يعني ان صح التعبير لاجل الكسب
اكثر لذا اعتقد ان السؤال والاسئله سوف
تطرح هي سوف تكون من وراء هذه الشخصيات
ومن هو الذي ضد الطرف اذا اعتقد اسئله
صعبه جدا وتحديات صعبه كما اشارتك في
البدايه سوف تواجهها الحكومه على وجه
الخصوص خاصه ان يعني هناك عدد يعني كبير
من المقاولين يعني مقربين من يعني الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان وهذه ممكن ان تكون هي
صدمه كبيره ومشكله تسبب له خاصه على الرغم
من في الفتره الاخيره شعبيته
صعدت وبعد التراجع قبل سنه ويمكن يكون لها
تاثير بشكل كبير على الانتخابات القادمه
شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول للكاتب المحلل
السياسي طه عوده
تمكنت فرق الانقاذ من انتشار سيده على قيد
الحياه من تحت الانقاذ بعد 175 او 175
ساعه على الزلزال في ولايه اتاي في جنوب
تركيا نقلت السيده على الفور الى المستشفى
لتلقي الاسعافات اللازمه
[موسيقى]
انا مش عارف جنازات سوريا
للاسف في جنازه عم تجي عائله كامله معهم
شخص واحد انا عم نحاول انه نساعد هذه
الجنائز اللي ما فيها صاحب او فيها عدد
قليل يعني ما بيحسن يتصرف اساسا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الى سوريا التي وصل فيها اعداد
القتلى الى
5300 على الاقل وفق ما افاده المرصد
السوري وهذه الارقام مرشحه ايضا للارتفاع
بسبب ضعف عمليات الانقاذ واستمرار الجدل
الحياه لادخال المساعدات الانسانيه
الدوليه منظمه
العربيه ان الوضع في سوريا ماساوي ويحتاج
للكثير من المساعدات وان مليوني شخص في
شمال سوريا كانوا اصلا في اوضاعهم سيئه
قبل الزلزال بدوره قال صندوق النقد الدولي
نوحان الوقت للوقوف مع الشعب السوري الذي
دمره الزلزال الامم المتحده اعلنت من
جهتها ان عمليات الانقاذ في سوريا اقتربت
بالنهايتها وانا الاولويه حاليا لتوفير
المساعدات مؤكده انها تعمل على نقل هذه
المساعدات من مناطق النظام الى المناطق
المنكوبه في شمال غرب سوريا
هذا يعقد مجلس الامن الدولي اليوم جلسه
لمناقشه امكانيه السماح للامم المتحده
بتوصيل المساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا عبر
اكثر من معبر حدودي تركي
سيطلع منسق الشؤون الانسانيه في الامم
المتحده مارتن بريفيت الذي يزور شمال
السوري سيطلع مجلس الامن الدولي على الوضع
الانساني في شمال سوريا وهنا يبرز دور
روسي حيث تضغط موسكو لتسليم المساعدات عن
طريق معابر يسيطر عليها النظام السوري في
الخطوط الاماميه مع مناطق المعارضه
الملكوبه
يوجد خلفي مجرد قطعه صغيره من الماساه
التي جاءت الى هنا في السادس من فبراير
لقد كنت اسمع قصصا هنا في حلب تقشعر لها
الابدان ما حدث في الساعات الاولى في هذا
اليوم
رهيب لحظه الزلزال منذ اسبوع هي اسوا ما
مر به هؤلاء الناس هناك اشخاص فقدوا
اطفالهم واخرون راحوا ضحيه الزلزال
لقد راينا ما يحدث في هذه المناطق جراء
الزلزال اثناء مرحله الانقاذ هناك من ظل
حيا وهناك من مات تحت الانقاض هذه المرحله
على وشك الانتهاء هناك حاجات ملحه لتوفير
الماوى والرعايه النفسيه والطعام والتعليم
هذا هو واجبنا الان
هذا ولا تزال مساعدات ومركز الملك سلمان
لغاته والاعمال الانسانيه تصل الى متضرر
الزلزالي في شمال غرب سوريا وبلغ عدد
الشاحنات المحمله بالمواد الغاثيه
والايوائيه اثناء عشره شاحنه حتى الان
فيما بدات عمليات توزيع المساعدات على
الاهل المتضرره من الزلزال في جنديرس ونصب
الخيام لمساعده الاهالي في توفير اماكن
يقيمون فيها بعد تدمير منازلهم وتستمر
الحمله السعوديه لاغاثه المتضررين من
الزلزال في استقبال التبرعات التي بلغت
اكثر من 320 مليون ريال بعد سته ايام من
اطلاقها
من معبر باب الهوى الحدود يا صحفي مصطفى
النعيمي مصطفى مرحبا بك معي اولا كيف
تتابع المشهد اذا كان هناك من جديد على
صعيد حجم المساعدات الانسانيه التي تدخل
من هذا المعبر وهو الشريان الرئيسي
للمناطق الحدوديه في شمال غرب سوريا
المشاهدين الكرام نعم لا شك ان شريان
الحياه بدا يتدفق مجددا وبوتيره اعلى اذا
ما اخذنا بان الاعتبار في بان فيها
الساعات الصباح الاولى بلغت احدى عشر
شاحنه دخلت من امامي من هنا مدينه انطاكيا
باتجاه معبر باب الهوى خلفي بهذا الاتجاه
تحركت السيارات ما زال السيارات الشحن ما
زالت تتدفق بهذا الاتجاه طبعا انا اتحدث
ما بين ما بين النشرتين هناك ساعتين ذهبت
فيها لمتابعه بعض الاحداث التي تجري من
حولي كالمستشفيات وحال المدينه التي انا
اتواجد فيها مدينه الريحانيه بالتحديد
كذلك عاده الحياه بشكل شبه كامل للمدينه
هنالك خدمات الانترنت خدمات الكهرباء
خدمات المطاعم المحل التجاريه كل شيء عادت
الى مهيته السابقه
بدا توزيع الخبز حتى في المحل محل
التجاريه بشكل كامل وبالعوده الى
المساعدات الامميه التي دخلت المساعدات
عفوا الانسانيه التي دخلت عبر جسر الجوي
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه باتت تتوزع بشكل
مستمر وذلك من خلال توزيعه ارسالها عبر
معبر الحمام ولربما قد نشهد في الساعات
القليله القادمه ايضا هنالك تدفق لمساعدات
الانسانيه جسر الملك سلمان الذي ياتي بشكل
مستمر باتجاه
مطار غازي عنتاب ومن غازي عنتاب شحنه برا
باتجاه معبر الحمام المحازي لمدينه جنديرس
الاكثر تضررا في الداخل السوري كذلك ايضا
يحيطها مدينه عفرين وهي ايضا متضرره يتم
توزيع الخيام والمساعدات الانسانيه
والاغاثيه تدريجيا على الاهالي المنكوبين
في هذه البلده المتضرره بشكل كبير
لاي الجهات هذه الشاحنات التي دخلت الان
التي رصدتها تتبع اخ مصطفى
وانما هي مساعدات من منظمات انسانيه تركيه
ترسل عبر الحدود من خلال معبر باب الهوى
تشرف على تسيير تلك الحافلات منظمه
التركيه وهي تضم مجموعه من المنظمات يعني
المحليه تقوم على ارسال المساعدات بشكل
مستمر حتى منذ بدايه الازمه وقبل ان ترسل
الامم المتحده تم ارسال مجموعه من
المساعدات الانسانيه الطارئه وهنا نتحدث
عن منظومه افاد بالوجه التحديد ارسلت خيام
ارسلت ولكن ارسلت الكثير يعني من معدات
لكن هل تكفي اعتقد بان غير كافيه لكن مع
تدفق او استمرار تدفق المساعدات الانسانيه
والمساعدات المعنيه
بتداعيات الكوارث اعتقد انها ستحد من حجم
الماساه بالعكس تماما ربما قد تساهم بشكل
او باخر عمليه في انقاذ بعض الارواح
بالدرجه الاولى خاصه ان الوقود بدا يتدفق
بشكل كبير منذ اليوم الثاني وحتى هذه
اللحظه التي يتحدث فيها هنالك صهاريج تدخل
باتجاهها قد الاراضي السوريه ومن الممكن
ان نسجل لكم بعض اثناء دخول او عبور تلك
الصهاريج الوقود باتجاه الحدود او باتجاه
معبر باب الهوى بالتحديد شكرا جزيلا لك
الصحفي مصطفى النعيمي من معبر باب الهوى
الحدودي
ايضا نبقى في سوريا حيث يصعب تحديد حجم
الاضرار الاقتصاديه التي اصابت البلاد
مقارنه بالجانب التركي وذلك للاوضاع
السياسيه المنتسمه ومعاناه البلاد من حرب
مستمره منذ اكثر من 12 عاما
خسائر متزايده في الارواح والاملاك
والاقتصاد سببه الزلزال المدمر الذي اصاب
سوريا الاسبوع الماضي ليضيف معاناه اضافيه
لاقتصاد انهكته صراعات سياسيه لاكثر من 12
عاما وما زالت مستمره غياب البيانات
الرسميه والشفافيه واتساع رقعات تاثير
الزلزال بين مناطق خاضعه للنظام واخرى
للمعارضه يزيدان من صعوبه تقدير حجم
الاضرار والتي تجاوزت بالمجمل عشرات
المليارات من الدولارات وحول الخسائر
الماديه افادت منظمه الخوذ البيضاء بان
اكثر من
375 مبنى انهار كليا واكثر من الف ومئتين
مبنى انهار جزئيا كما تصدعت الاف المباني
الاخرى كما اصاب الزلزال اقتصاد سوريا
مقتل خاصه انه ضرب اربعه محافظات مسؤوله
عن اكثر من ثلث اقتصاد البلاد
فمحافظه حلب المتاثره الاكبر من الزلزال
مسؤوله عن اكثر من 16% من اقتصاد سوريا
فيما تمثل محافظه حماه المرتبه الخامسه
بنسبه مساهمه في الاقتصاد السوري بما يصل
الى تسعه في المئه ثم اللاذقيه في المرتبه
السادسه بسبعه فاصل ثمانيه في المئه
مساهمه بالاقتصاد اما محافظه ادلب التي
تنقسم السيطره فيها بين النظام والمعارضه
والمتاثره بالزلزال تصل مساهمتها في
الاقتصاد الى 2.7
انقسام الوضع السياسي في سوريا يزيد من
معاناه متاثرين بالزلزال المدمر اعاده
الاعمار على الجانب السوري خاصه في
المناطق التي تخضع للمعارضه والتي في
الاصل تضم مئات الالاف من المهجرين ستكون
الاصعب في غياب رقابه حكوميه وهرب من
المسؤوليه من المنظمات الانسانيه الدوليه
شادي الزعيم العربيه
هذا ويشكو القطاع الصحي في مناطق الشمال
سوريا بالنقص المستلزمات الطبيه وضعف
التمويل لمواجهه اثار الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب المنطقه قبل نحو اسبوع اما الكادر
الطبي فحدث ولا حركه حيث يخدم طبيب واحد
عشره الاف شخص في ظل ظروف الزلزال الحاليه
[موسيقى]
اربعه بالليل للساعه 4:00 العصر يا
طالعوني
اجيت على المستشفى وصار غسلت كليتي مرتين
وهي الثالثه يمكن
[موسيقى]
نا كتير اصابات من الزلزال اصابات كانت
شديده للاسف المرضى اللي عم يطلعوا من تحت
الانقاط في عندهم كان هرس عضلي هذا القمر
عمل لعبة كتير علينا لانه نحن بالاساس ما
عنا هاي المستلزمات دعارات التحال الدموي
وهي دارات مكلفه
تعرض مشفى الامومه الدانه سامز
لتصدعات كبيره تم بفضل الله عز وجل اخلاء
المرضى والكادر بالسرعه القصوى للحفاظ على
سلامتهم
[موسيقى]
الدكتور محمد الحاج علي الطبيب في الخدمات
الطبيه البريطانيه رئيس الجمعيه السوريه
الورديه دكتور محمد حياك الله معي في هذه
التغطيه
دكتور اليوم هو الثامن على هذا الزلزال
ثلاث الى اربع حالات نجد حتى الان امراه
في عمر الثمانين طفله سبعه اعوام كذلك رجل
بالاضافه الى
مولوده بالامس سؤال دكتور كيف يمكن لمثل
هذه الحالات ان تبقى على قيد الحياه حتى
هذا اليوم هل ما زالت فرص البقاء على قيد
الحياه
موجوده وارده حتى الان
حياك الله اخي خالد اسعد الله اوقاتك
واوقات الساده المشاهدين اسمح لي فقط في
ثواني قبل ان اجيب على هذا السؤال انا
اقول احيي جميع زملائي الذين يعملون في
ظروف انسانيه صعبه في هذه المنطقه بعد 12
عام من التضحيات والان تاتي باسات الزلزال
زملاء الذين درست معهم على مقاعد كليه
الطب في جامعه حلب يعني انحني احتراما لهم
واقول انتم ابطال في العمل الانساني وقدوه
لنا جميعا ونحن نحتدي بكم اذا عدت الى
سؤالك
الفتره الذهبيه عاده لانقاذ الضحايا من
تحت الانقاض هي فتره 72 ساعه يعني فتره
يعني نتحدث هنا عن ثلاثه ايام تقريبا هذه
هي الفتره الذهبيه كل ما ابتعدنا عن ثلاثه
ايام تتضائل هذه الفرصه اكثر فاكثر وعاده
المعايير الموضوعه من قبل الامم المتحده
لايقاف عمليه البحث هي خمسه حتى سبعه ايام
عندما يتوقف العثور على الناجين العوامل
التي تحدد فرص النجاح عاده
وجود منفذ للاكسجين وجود الماء عدم وجود
كسور او اصابات رديه شديده يتعرض لها
الجسم بالاضافه الى درجات الحراره التي
يتواجد فيها هذا الشخص العالق تحت الالقاب
بالتالي هل هذه هي العوامل تنطبق الان على
هذه الحالات يعني طفله مثلا او مولوده
الدكتور محمد
هل العوامل تختلف معها
لكل قاعده وينبغي دراسه كل حاله بحالتها
وظروفها ولكن عاده يعني اذا كان المكان ذو
منفذ قليل الاكسجين مثلا وارتفعت نسبه
ثاني اكسيد الكربون فالشخص يتوفى
بالاختناعات اذا كان مثلا الطقس بارد جدا
وهذا ما زاد ماساتنا اكثر فاكثر كما
شاهدنا مع درجات الحراره المنخفضه فهذا
يصعب من المساله عدم وجود الماء يستطيع
الجسم البقاء لمده ثلاثه ايام بدون شرب
الماء مثلا بعد ذلك تصبح الامور اصعب اذا
كان هناك اصابات وكسور رضيه شديده مثلا
وهناك اذيه يعني تحدث في اعضاء اخرى او
اصابه بالقصور الكلوي فهذا يعني يزيد من
احتماليه الوفاه ويقلل من فرص النجاه طبعا
هذه الحالات حالات استثنائيه حالات نادره
جدا الارقام التي ذكرتها يعني لا تتجاوز
اصابع اليد الواحده ويعني نحن نتالم كثيرا
الان بعد مرور سبعه ايام وتضاؤل فرص
العثور على ناجين من تحت الالقاب لكن ندعو
الله عز وجل ان يعني يتلطف باهل هؤلاءك
الذين اصيبوا ونقلوا الى المستشفيات لان
المشكله هناك ايضا كبيره وكارثيه الوضع
صعب في المناطق السوريه خاصه في مناطق
الشمال الغربي بسبب نقص الكوادر الصحيه
اصلا بسبب المشاكل ايضا التي يعانيها
القطاع الصحي بشكل عام في هذه
المناطق بالتالي كيف تتصور او ترى ما يبذل
من جهود الاوضاع ايضا لهؤلاء الى اي مدى
هناك اليوم فرصه للعثور على ناجي مع هذه
الحاله يعني صعبه
كبيره جدا جدا المنظمه الطبيه السوريه
الامريكيه سانز والمنظمه الطبيه السوريه
البريطانيه
مثلا او مشافي ميدانيه ولكن انه اول كثيرا
على اشقائنا في الوطن العربي الكبير
اشقائنا في مملكه الخير المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ان تقدم المدد وتقدم شريان
الحياه في هذه المستشفيات تحتاج الى
الوقود حتى تبقى الطاقه الكهربائيه تعمل
في هذه المستشفيات تحتاج الى المستلزمات
الطبيه الكبيره وتحتاج الى ايضا طواقم
طبيه وان شاء الله هناك العديد من الزملاء
حول العالم
الجاهزين للدخول الى تلك المناطق ومساحه
زملائه هناك زملائنا هناك يعني على مدى 12
عام تعلمنا منهم الكثير والكثير
والان ياتي فصل اضافي تعلم بانه القوات
البيضاء انه يعني او صرحوا بانتهاء عمليات
الانقاذ تركيز الجهود على يعني انتشار
الجثث قبل 24 او 48 ساعه يا دكتور قبل حتى
الموعد الذي يمكن للفرق لانقاذ ان توقف
عملياتها البحثيه
عاده يعني عندما تصل الى الخمسه ايام يعني
اخر 24 ساعه منها لا يعثر على ناجين
فتتوقف عمليات البحث هذا هو الموضوع من
قبل اللغه المتحده طبعا المشكله الان التي
اصبحت تصادف كما نقرا هي
تحلل الجثث وتعفر الجثث ايضا تحت الالقاب
وهذا سيقول الى مشكلات صحيه تاليه ايضا
طبعا لا ننسى ايضا ان يعني شبكات المياه
النظيفه تاثرت شبكات الصرف الصحي تهدمت
يعني كل هذا سيزيد من عمق الكارثه الصحيه
ولذلك نناشد اخواننا في مملكه الخير ايضا
ان يبقوا مع اخوانهم في الشمال الغربي في
سوريا والمملكه كانت من اوائل من دخل الى
هذه المنطقه والساعه فنقول لهم جميعا
جزاكم الله كل خير مملكه الخير شكرا جزيلا
لك من كارديف الدكتور محمد الحاج علي
الطبيب في الخدمات الطبيه البريطانيه رئيس
الجمعيه السوريه الويلزيه
نوصل معكم تغطيه للزلزال لكن نتوقف الان
مع بعض الاخبار الخاصه بملفات اخرى حيث
نصح حتى الولايات المتحده مواطنيها
بمغادره روسيا فورا بسبب الحرب في
اوكرانيا واحتمال تعرضهم للاعتقال التعسفي
او مضايقات من جانب وكالات الفهد القانون
الروسي وقالت السفاره الامريكيه في موسكو
انه ينبغي على المواطنين الامريكيين
المقيمين في روسيا والمسافرين اليها
مغادرتها على الفور بسبب احتمال وقوع
عمليات اعتقال بدون سند قانوني جاء ذلك
بعد ان اعتقلت اجهزه الامن الروسيه مواطني
امريكيين بسبب اتهامات زائفه كما اصدرت
ادانات بحقهم في محاكمات سريه او بدون
تقديم ادله ذات مصداقيه وفق السفاره
الامريكيه في موسكو
ابدا متحدثون باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه استعداد بلاده للجلوس الى
الطاوله المفاوضات النوويه مجددا لكن
المسؤول الايرانيه شدد في الوقت نفسه على
ضروره اظهار واشنطن حسن النوايا
وكذلك طالب المسؤول الاداره الامريكيه
بالالتزام بما تصرح به علنا في وسائل
الاعلام مشيرا الى التزام ايران بمسار
المفاوضات وعوده كافه الاطراف للاتفاق
النووي وفق قوله
اكدت مصادر عسكريه في ولايه لوغانس كان
وحدات من القوات الاوكرانيه المتمركزه في
قريه ماكييفكا تستخدم سكان المدنيين كدروع
بشريه ولا تسمح لهم بالخروج من القريه
وقالت ان المقاتلين الاوكرانيين لا يطلقون
سراح المدنيين في مكيفكا
لمواقعهم التي شيدت في منازل السكان
المحليين واشارت ايضا الى قيام قوه الامن
في كييف بزرع الالغام على الطرق المؤديه
الى شمال وجنوب وشرق مكيفكا من اجل منع
الناس من المغادره
اعلن البنتاجون ان واشنطن تواصلت اخيرا مع
بكين بشان المنطقه الصيني بعد عده محاولات
لاجراء حوار معها وكان وزير الدفاع
الامريكي اوستن طلب التحدث مع نظيره صيني
بوعيده اسقاط مقاتله تابعه للقوات الجويه
الامريكيه
للمنطاد الصيني قباله الساحل الشرقي
للولايات المتحده لكنه لم يتلقى اي رد على
الرغم من ان الحادثه دفعت وزير الخارجيه
الى الغاء رحله الى بكين كانت مقربه منذ
فتره طويله قالت الصين انها رفضت الاتصال
مع وزير الدفاع الامريكي بسبب قرار واشنطن
غير المسؤول حسب وصفها باسقاط المنتد
المنطاد
السلطات الايرانيه عن المخرج السينمائي
محمد رسولوف بعد اكثر من سته اشهر على
اعتقاله بسبب انتقاداته للحكومه وفق اعلام
ايراني الفائز بجوائز عده بينها الجائزه
الاولى في مهرجان برلين السينمائي الدولي
يعد احدا الفنانين والمشاهير البارزين
الذين ثقلوا في الاشهر الاخيره الانتقادهم
حمله الحكومه على الاحتجاجات
[موسيقى]
نهايه هذه الساعه تغطيتنا عبر شاشه
العربيه المستمر الان تسحبكم زميله ميسون
حسن
[موسيقى]